how are you feeling this is my first
event out amazing this is my first red
carpet in two years
uh and it is amazing to be back it's
amazing to see how many fans are lining
the street
on hollywood boulevard i was not
expecting that and it's amazing to see
them
and excited to finally bring black widow
to the world
i have to know how you're feeling though
it is it bittersweet in a way because
it is a swan song for this character
that we've known and loved since the
beginning of the mcu
it is but you know marvel is always
about new beginnings and scarlett
johansson is such an amazing
partner for us she was a producer on
this film she was the one that brought
us
uh our amazing director kate shortland
um and
i am excited to continue working with
her in any way possible if we're so
lucky
i was gonna say is there a possibility
she could like come back in some way
nice answer okay but it is an
opportunity to also set up a lot of
characters that may or may not have a
big future in the mcu and a lot of
people are talking about florence pew is
there anything you can tell us about
well i will say it was important to
scarlett that she wanted to create a new
ensemble for this film to to inform
people about natasha's past about her
origins
and that meant a new family that we
hadn't seen before uh and florence pugh
as elena elena is a character we've
wanted to bring into the universe for
many many
years and florence pugh is such a
spectacular actress
soon after we hired her she was
nominated for an academy award she is so
i i can't wait for people to see it and
the scenes between she and scarlett in
this movie
and that that banter and that new
relationship uh elevates both of them
and the entire
mcu i'm so excited now i got to tell you
i i met you one time and all the press
had just got back from star wars
celebration
i don't know if you remember this you
were so interested in everything that
happened at star wars celebration
and now the fact that you're developing
a star wars movie i feel like it feels
so right knowing how big of a fan you
are
i have to know why it feels right for
you now and were you hesitant
to head to a galaxy far far away i'm so
hesitant that i'm not even going to talk
about it today
that's how hesitant i am about it but i
do love star wars and i love star wars
celebration
and i've been to two of them i think
maybe three of them
i don't remember that but i it makes
sense that i would ask people how how it
was
yeah and what was revealed i i mean i
got it we i mean
big fans look at that yeah yeah yeah
yeah nice i'm married to the
from the christ that's awesome well okay
if you want to say i should have seen
that question coming if if i was
attentive enough there is a
about 80 chance if i'm doing an
interview i will be bringing up star
wars with anybody
i'm sorry i can't help it um well
speaking of working with michael waldron
loki is in the midst right now this is
the third marvel series
i have to know just based on like now
this being the third one
kind of what you've learned from doing
marvel tv and what you see for the
future of marvel television like could
we see like a marvel tv team up
a lot of the avengers well maybe again
we don't really look at it we're not
looking at his tv teams or movie teams
it's all one universe now it's all one
big mcu
and uh and i hope what people have taken
away from
juan division and falconer soldier and
loki and seeing black widows soon
is how unique and different all the
corners of the mcu can be
the fact that people i saw some cosplay
here tonight of the tva
yeah and that makes me so excited nobody
outside of very very particular comic
nerds like myself had
heard of the tva and now that's
something that people are embracing and
wondering when will the tva come back
that's what disney plus has given us is
an ability to tell more
deeper further stories that will have
ramifications across
features and uh series absolutely i'm
loving it too and i'm very excited to
see what's in store for the
emmys you know what i'm saying like it's
a new thing we could finally get some of
these people recognize lizzie and emmy
for her
i'll tell you the lizzie olson's work
all of the cast on these shows have done
such tremendous tom hiddleston
anthony mackie sebastian stan paul
bettany they're amazing that's one of
the reasons we want to do the show
because lizzie olson is a spectacular
actress we wanted to give her a showcase
to show everything that she could do and
boy did she
yeah and i gotta know okay there's a lot
of casting talk out there
poor emily blunt and drunk kaczynski
can't get through an interview without
being asked about fan casting for
fantastic four
will there be any news on that front
soon uh i don't think it's soon and you
know this is our first red carpet event
in two years we'll see what happens with
upcoming uh
gatherings and fan events where we can
release more uh news i hope sometime in
the near future yeah what do you think
of alfred molina just just dropping he's
in spider-man no way
home uh you know people uh people can
talk
i'm not people get a microphone some
people like to talk
some people like me not so much
everything we make is hopefully the
intention of of uh exceeding
expectations
and fulfilling surprises not every rumor
you read about online is true
uh not by long shot but not everyone is
false either so
that's the that's the fun and even
seeing people watch our shows now
releasing them week to week is a new
experience for us
and seeing the speculation that occurs
online between each episode some of that
speculation
is right some of it is wrong all of it
informs
us on some level in i think fun ways
there are so many newcomers
coming to the mcu we're building this
whole new phase here
is there anyone who uh that comes to
mind who's like really
stuck out for you in terms of somebody
you're like wow i didn't realize but the
fans are gonna grab onto this character
so much i mean i think you've seen that
even over the over the course of this
film with florence pugh and david harbor
and rachel vice and certainly in the
disney plus series with owen wilson
and i'll tell you somebody who was one
of our dream casting for many years
julie louise dreyfus
uh and uh and uh she popped up in falcon
winter soldier that was a dream come
true for us
so and we really don't look at it as
people we are lucky that these
that these amazing talents are joining
the mcu yeah um
uh not the other way around is there
anything you can tell us about like what
her future could be what she's kind of
building towards
you should ask alfred molina i will ask
alfred molina
good answer thank you so much thank you
thanks very much
thank you